[Music]
we had a first regular council meeting
of the year of every meeting it wasn't a
particularly denying meeting that we did
start the meeting now and for a moment
silence in memory of Karen Eastwood who
was recently died she's a member of the
audience section community board also
for Peter mcmorran from Oxford who was a
past counselor and the last chair of
oxford county council and with richard
kaka who was one of our staff members
who work for quite a long time in the
building unit we also acknowledged the
three local recipients of honors in the
New Year's Honours List so that serve as
a nicer thing to be able to do the
meeting itself I guess the two main
areas of discussion one was our
submission to parliamentary select
committee on government proposal to
shift the responsibility for Florida in
water from councils to district health
boards none of the water supplies and
one are very fluoridated and I've had my
time very little demand for that to
happen our preferences that it's a
national issue related to digital health
and should be dealt with nationally the
other matter that we dealt with at the
council meeting we looked at the
question whether we should have an
independent member of wood and Risk
Committee a number of councils around
the country do that but in me and our
council decided that the quality of our
staff and and in the kind of oversight
that we can give is elected members we
didn't need to do that
[Music]